now I'm going to talk to you I'm going
to talk to you about a book by saint
gregory of nyssa it's called a life of
moses and there's i checked it out
they're the two copies of it of it back
there if you have never read this book
you really have to read this book the
theme of conference is encountering God
and I have to be honest when I was
exploring orthodoxy when I was a
catechumen just trying to figure
figuring things out when I read st.
Gregory's book I mean coming from a
Protestant background having all the
Bible stories just you know really
deeply in my memory
reading reading st. Gregory's book is
just was like constant lightning bolt I
was just reading the book and just
couldn't believe it he was
just connecting everything together and
making everything just makes so much
sense you know and so what I was hoping
to do and I've never I've never done
this before is that as I continued my
life as I continued as I converted is I
could explore iconography as I explored
other writers I was just always come
back and in the back of my mind I would
oh I realized that I had this program
running in the back of my mind and it
was basically st. Gregory's book and it
just informs yesterday I told you about
talked about patterns and stories and
and this book where say Gregory does is
the pattern is there in the scripture
but what a Gregory does is the way he
speaks about things and he act the
analogy is that he threads together he
just shows it to you so what I'm going
to try to do today is I'm going to try
to take you on that journey I'm going to
try to trace the basic pattern in Saint
Gregory's book now his book is extremely
expansive if you talked about a lot of
things that could never you can't
I couldn't capture it all here but I'm
going to trace of the basic pattern
about of what's in there and hopefully
it will help people understand first of
all what I'm talking about when I talk
about these patterns and
then as everybody here has we all had
the experience of the liturgy the
experience of Scripture hopefully will
it will will spark some some of your
intuitions to kind of start to see those
connections I mean everybody has already
seen them but hopefully we'll it will be
a part of to help you to get through
that experience so the idea is that in
st. Gregory's book or in the scripture
and everything the heat race is a
pattern of the world basically a pattern
of the cosmos and when I when I talk
about a pattern or a map of the world
we're not talking about the kind of map
that you get on Google Maps or you know
like a physical map but it's a map of of
meaning that that are threaded together
and really what it is it's a map of our
own journey it's a map of of our ascent
of the the ladder of divine ascent
because the story in st. Gregory's book
the basic structure of his stories he
traces the the life of Moses as he
ascends of the mountain and this ascent
of the mountain is basically the same as
what we're seeing in this icon of the
ascent of the holy ladder and so going
up the mountain is the gradual is this
gradual ascent towards divinity but at
the same time it's our participation in
the church if you look at the icon
that's up now you can see that you can
see that the beginning of the ladder is
is the church and then through the
church and up the ladder we move up
towards this divine encounter which we
which we find at the top of the ladder
and so in st. Gregory what he does is he
connects all these things together so
the base of the mountain that Moses is
going to ascend which he does is she
gives us these images of what the base
of the mountain looks like or what it
looks like before we
again the journey before we enter onto
the journey and the images that he uses
are all these images of flesh these
images of all the things that are
outside our nature all these things that
are added to our nature the things that
are foreign to us and the basic image
that he threads through is these image
of the garments of skin when Adam and
Eve fell in the garden what God gave
them as they were chased away from the
garden were these garments of skin
around them these garments of dead
animal skins and that's like that's the
basic image that Saint Gregory uses at
the bottom of the of the mountain so
here's this is going to be our mountain
people can be very simple I'm not an
artist today I'm just just a speaker and
so the bottom of the mountain told you
is the garments of skin but it's also we
could cut we could send it to the
narthex okay so it's the place where the
church end and the world begins so the
bottom of the mountain is what Gregory
calls quote the seat of the soul and
that it's the passionate and appellative
parts of our soul is where our appetites
are our passions are located in the
human soul and so the top of the
mountain is is the place where we
encounter God so it's the intellect it's
the higher part of the soul where we're
capable of grasping the nature of things
but at the same time because the bottom
of the soul the bottom of the mountain
is an Arctic then the top the top of the
mountain also appears as the sanctuary
and as we talked about yesterday
beyond the sanctuary in the highest
place of our being that's where we
encounter this divine tabernacle that's
where that's where Moses received the
pattern of the divine tabernacle and the
divine Tabernacle I think Gregory told
us that's Christ
himself okay its Christ as the universal
origin and container of all things so
that's the basic pattern already giving
you like the just a basic pattern that
st. Gregory traits is in the book and
what it does is it joins if you look at
the elements already there it joins the
personal to the communal so it's a body
but it's a community as the church and
then ultimately it's all it leads us up
to what is the most to the highest to
the spiritual and to the uncreated and
so when I as you see what I'm starting
to do and this is what I'm going to be
doing is that I'm going to use st.
Gregory's words and I'm actually going
to create a visual map of what he is
brew of the journey that he's bringing
us on and at the end you'll see why I'm
doing that now the first thing the first
important thing as we do this as we look
at the elements that st. Gregory brings
together and this is a rule I think for
all our interpretations of symbols in
the Bible or in the liturgy is that
symbols are not moral things that is the
elements that we find in the liturgy are
the elements that we find in the Bible
they're neither they're not necessarily
good or bad the things in themselves so
they're their places of meaning you
could say okay so what's important on
this map of meaning isn't so much where
the thing is on the map but which
direction is it pointing to so if you
think back at that at that ladder of
divine ascent doesn't matter how high
you are on the ladder if you're falling
down you're falling down if you're at
the bottom of the ladder but you're
going up you're much in a much better
place than that person at the top who's
falling down and so everything in this
map of meaning is has a dual a dual
possibility we could say it could have a
light side or a dark side and so because
we're talking about a trip I'm going to
start with the actual movement of the
trip and in the movement
the mountain there's two possibilities
right you can go up or it can come down
and in st. Gregory's description of this
it's actually it's very it's really
interesting because he shows us this
duality how the same thing can have a
light and a dark side and so the way he
does is he talks about Aaron's about
Moses's brother Aaron okay so I hope
everybody knows the story of Moses
because I couldn't go through too much
of the details of the actual story but
Aaron was Moses's brother and God chose
Aaron to be Moses's helper so the wage
st. Gregory interprets that he says that
Aaron is akin is an app is analogical to
our guardian angel that angel that God
places with us to counsel us to entice
us into making that ascent of the divine
ladder of the mountain and he and that
angel does this to reasonable thoughts
and to encouragement but if you know the
story of Moses you know that Aaron is
also the one who made the golden calf
right and who brought the brought Israel
to engage in licentiousness and idolatry
so how do we reconcile those two things
so that well Gregory tells us a secret
he tells us that quote there the
doctrine which derives its
trustworthiness from the tradition of
the fathers which says that after our
nature fell into sin God did not
disregard our fall and withhold his
Providence no on the one hand he
appointed an angel with an incorporeal
nature to help in the life of each
person now the other hand he also
appointed a Corrupter who by an evil and
malicious demon afflict the life of man
and contrives against our nature okay so
what are we talking about I think most
people here we know what he's referring
to and what he's referring to is this
and I think I mean that the faster that
we just reconcile ourselves with the
fact that this is what you're talking
about the best because the imagery might
seem silly on a first reading but if but
it's only silly if we're materialists
who think that angels are you know
fleshy people with wings and devils have
spiky tail but once we get rid of the
material is blindfolded often and traps
us then we experience this every day of
our lives I mean anybody who has fought
a passion or else given into a passion
then suddenly wakes up and think like
why did I do that you know where does
that come from
I mean everybody knows that we have this
fight in us all the time but if you're
struggling with this image if you find
it too difficult to to accept and I've
already showed you this image in iconic
form at the beginning it's this one look
at what's happening on that image on one
side there are the Angels encouraging
and on the other side there are the
demons bringing down all right so the
brother who is our counsellor or we
could we could call him that little
voice in our head our conscious whatever
you want to call it can become a vehicle
for the angel or the demon depending on
which side the person decides to go
right which way we decide to move so now
we've got this notion of movement so we
can start the trip we can start the trip
same oldest stuff st. Gregory starts at
the beginning of Moses's journey starts
at the birth of Moses and as most of you
know when Moses was born there was a law
Pharaoh made a law because there were
too many Israel like children and the
law was that all the male children were
to be killed and so st. Gregory
interprets this and he tells us for the
material and passionate disposition to
which human nature is carried when it
falls is the female form of life
whose birth is favored by the tyrant the
austerity and intensity of virtue is the
male version which is hostile to the
tyrants and suspected of insurrection
against his rule
so my trouble yes all right we've got
materiality and passions related to the
female form and austerity and virtue
related to the male ok so right away our
modern our modern minds are bothered
with this and I can understand that I
totally get it but we just hold that
thought
ok just hold it just a little bit ok
because if you really read that quote
I'm going to make you read it again if
you really read that quote you'll see
that hiding in that quote is actually
also the dark side of the masculine ok
and that's the tyrant ok so don't worry
everything will balance out you'll see
st. Gregory balances everything out in
fact st. Gregory starts by telling us
that Moses right then Moses had two
mothers ok
and because in order to protect Moses
from the Pharaoh he's placed in the
basket you know the story plates in a
basket on the Nile and found by an
Egyptian princess so thank Reger he
tells us the daughter of the king being
childless in barren I think she is
rightly perceived as profane philosophy
arranged to be called his mother by
adopting the youngster for truly barren
is profaned education so the adoptive
mother of Moses is knowledge of the
world
it's profane natural philosophy today we
would say science technology all that
type of knowledge and say Gregory warns
us that it can sometimes impede our
spiritual journey and this is the
foreign princess but Moses is birth
mother who continued to care for him
while he was being raised by the
Egyptian while Gregor tells us that it's
the church and it's teaching so already
now we start to seeds right at the
beginning we start to see the other side
of the feminine which appears so the
feminine is the periphery in the sense
of the womb okay that which surrounds us
but at the risk of going into cliches
that sometimes we share they're useful
it is both the womb and the tomb if you
will as so st. Gregory uses the image of
a fruitful womb in his natural mother
compared to a quote womb of barren
wisdom so what it is it's both the
church which contains us but also the
outer world which is our dissipation
okay so two things which surround us so
that's why it is the periphery both the
church which contains us and the outer
world which is our dissipation so if we
if we continue with this idea of
periphery we've already talked about the
foreign princess and so what Gregory
develops is is this idea of the foreign
this idea of the foreign as this outside
thing so that Gregory develops this
whole idea that the subjugation of the
Israelites to the Egyptians in the book
of Exodus is an image of the subjugation
of the human person to what is added or
exterior to our nature we could be the
tyranny of our flesh our desires but it
could also be these foreign
foreknowledge foreign education all
these things which are on the outside
which which can trap us
so when Moses grows out we know this
story as well he suddenly feels this
attachment to Hebrews to his own people
who were slaves in Egypt and one day
Moses killed an Egyptian who he sees
abusing an Israelite quote Moses teaches
us by his own example to take our stand
with virtue as with a kinsman and to
kill virtues adversary the victory of
true religion is the death and
destruction of idolatry
so slavery to foreign elements idolatry
being the best example of them can
appear like we've seen as tyranny as the
Pharaoh who imposes himself on on us but
it can also appear as seduction and so
in the story of Moses we have these
stories of foreign women women from
other nations who seduce the Israelite
men and bring ideology with them so even
after fighting and escaping the foreign
tyrants they fall back through seduction
quote it was only to be expected that
some among them would be filled with
lust for unlawful intercourse with
foreigners unquote so the foreign women
are idolatry the slavery to our passions
okay so am I in trouble again all right
they are the barren and profane velocity
but you see the Greger is not done with
us because there's a trick in this story
and the trick is that most Moses had a
foreign wife and Moses married a foreign
woman so here again we start to see the
two sides of the symbolism start to
manifest itself quote the foreign wife
will follow him for there are certain
things derived from profane education
which should not be rejected when we
propose to give birth to virtue
indeed moral and natural philosophy may
become at certain
the comrade friend the companion of life
to a higher way provided that the
offering of this union introduced
nothing of a foreign defilement and
what's really important as Christians to
understand and our own symbolism is that
Moses's wife is the one who circumcised
Moses his son okay remember that
circumcision is the cutting off of the
garments of skin according to Moses so
the foreskin is removed as this mark of
the foreigner quote since his son had
not been circumcised so as to cut off
completely everything hurtful and impure
his wife appeased the angel when she
presented her offspring as pure by
completely removing that marked by which
the foreigner was known
well Gregory does is she beautifully
weaves in the image of circumcision with
the notion of baptism okay so if the
foreign is removed by the foreign wife
so - in baptism death is removed by
death okay so down there we could say
between the foreign tyranny of the
Pharaoh and the mountain of the divine
ascent there is that water which is also
death and one must go through the waters
in order to begin the journey so of
course that Gregory for st. Gregory this
is the crossing of the Red Sea that's
what the crossing of the Red Sea means
it's our baptism that commences our
journey on to this divine ascent so
Moses split the water then crossed the
Red Sea pursued by the Egyptians on whom
the water closed quote after we have
drowned the whole Egyptian person that
in every form of evil in the saving
baptism we emerge alone dragging along
nothing foreign in our subsequent life
unquote and the garments of skin
this outer fleshy part is called dead
and earthly and they're related to our
animal aspect because that's what they
are they're dead animal skins added to
our nature so for example when Moses
comes back down from the mountain after
his ascent saying Gregory makes a huge
deal to the fact that animals were not
allowed to even touch the base of the
mountain he says quote that none of the
irrational animals was allowed to appear
on the mountain signified in my opinion
that the contemplation of the
intelligible in the contemplation of the
intelligible we surpassed the knowledge
which originates with the senses unquote
that sounds platonic but we're not done
and the removal of the garments of skin
they appear the strongest with Moses
ascends to encounter the burning bush I
mean if you remember the story God has
God asked Moses to do before he comes to
the burning bush God asked him to remove
his sandals and Saint Gregory relates
this removal of the sandals to the
removal of the garment to skin quote
sandaled feet cannot ascend that height
where the light of truth is seen but the
dead and earthly covering of skins
which was placed around our nature at
the beginning must be removed from the
feet of the soul but even this removal
finds a surprising duality in st.
Gregory because when Saint Gregory
describes the burning bush he insists on
the fact that the burning bush was a
thorn bush and he says it a few times
for you to really notice that it's not
just a bush it's a thorn bush now why
why would he insist on the fact that
it's a thorn bush quote Moses on that on
that occasion attained to this knowledge
of true being so now does everyone who
liked him divest himself of the earthly
covering and look to the light shining
from the bramble bush that is to the
radiance which shines upon us
through this thorny flesh which as the
gospel says the tree is it and which is
as the gospel says the true light and
the truth itself so think about that
quote for a minute and in the book of
Genesis one of the consequences of the
fall of Adam and Eve is that creation is
going to produce thorns and that's that
if the hostility of creation appears in
the image of thorns and the garments of
skin which God gives to Adam are meant
to protect them from the consequence of
that fall and the image of which is
those thorns on the bushes but here just
as Moses remove that outer fleshy
covering of sick of skin which is the
consequence of the fall where does he
see the light he sees the light coming
through the thorn bush and as st.
Gregory says himself coming through the
thorny flesh so st. Gregory always
preserves those two things all the
removals will come back and you'll see
is an amazing thing to watch and this
question of the periphery of the bottom
of the mountain it comes to its limit
which is chaos complete chaos and
Gregory uses this image of clay as this
chaos so what he does is he connects the
slavery of the Israelites in the foreign
land to what they're doing in the
foreign land and what are they doing
they're forced to make by a foreigner to
make bricks out of clay quote for this
demon who does men harm and corrupts
them is intensely concerned that in
subjects not look to heaven but that
they stoop to earth and make bricks with
themselves
within themselves out of the clay and
let's understand this clay as this
hatched form thing as this mud and take
regulated to the frogs that come out
during the plagues as this ambiguous
Creed
that is both in land and on land and in
water and doesn't have its place so it's
really this chaos that exists on the
border of everything on the board of
what of what exists so when we think
about the different if you think about
the different elements I look at them up
on the screen if you think about the
different elements of periphery that
I've mentioned it only takes a moment to
realize that that's just how we we
experience the world right the feminine
as the womb right this house it contains
us and the world around
it's the foreigner that we encounter
coming from the other side of the border
the passions which make us idolaters and
dissipate us to the outside and the
animal which is a body without the flesh
without reason and finally clay that
ambiguity and confusion that comes when
order or the center no longer hold and
all of these example they're how we
personally experienced this periphery so
we need to be clear that when Moses
ascends the mountain
it is really described as a divesting
right as the removal of those sandals as
the purification from the attachment to
peripheral things and there's also a
rare offical where the mass of the
people stay down at the bottom of the
mountain and as he moves up there's this
verification father Steven mentioned
that yesterday the 70 go up with Moses
but by the time Moses reaches the very
top where he encounters God and receives
the the law he is alone and so from the
quantity up to the one and so it's
somewhat like the high priest who is the
only one who can reach all the way into
the Holy of Holies and so this echoes
the actual shape of a mountain it's the
actual shape of the mountain which is
large at the base and just moves up to a
narrower and narrower summit okay so
when we have this image of a mountain in
the Bible as this
place of Epiphany at this place of
encountering God it's not arbitrary the
fact of mountains is the very experience
going up a mountain and reaching the top
and all of a sudden you see the entire
world around you it's the best image of
what it means to enter that unity in
which under which is that connection to
what unites everything together and so
the movement of the mountain is the
movement of this pattern of meaning
which I mentioned and think Gregory
makes a big deal about that and this
movement is off both we could say the
epistemological and ontological
hierarchy of beings that the Gregory
formulated in a very particular way he
explains that Moses ascent of the
mountain is Moses discovery of the true
knowledge of being so by removing the
sandal and seeing the light and the
bramble bush he's moving away from
dependent beings so when I say dependent
beings what I mean is everything
everything that's created is dependent
on God but when we see those things
that's isolated in themselves and we
don't see them as being connected to God
then that's when they become dangerous
that's when they become said Gregory
called them a type of falsehood so as
Moses is moving up he's moving towards
being itself from which dependent beings
find their find their meaning and
coherence and again that's an analogous
to the movement up from the multiplicity
of the base up to the unity of the
summit the bottom of the mountain is
assimilated with darkness and as Moses
goes up he encounters light and music
the source of visual and auditory
meaning but to enter the divine chamber
the sanctuary Moses must encounter God
in higher darkness as father Stephen
mentioned yesterday
so quote what does it mean that Moses
entered the darkness and then saw God in
it what is now recounted seems somehow
to be contradictory to the first
theophany for then the divine would be
held in light but now he is seen in
darkness let us not think that this is
at variance with the sequence of things
we have contemplated spiritually
scripture teaches us by this that
religious knowledge comes at first to
those who perceive it as light therefore
it is perceived to be contrary to
religion is darkness down there I'm
sorry I don't have a map of anyone and
the escape from the darkness comes about
when one participates in the light but
as the mind progresses and to an even
greater and more perfect diligence comes
to apprehend reality as it approaches
more nearly to contemplation it sees
more clearly what the divine nature is
unconcentrated unquote and then as I
explained yesterday even beyond that
divine darkness what does Moses
encounter he encounters the pattern of
the tabernacle now the pattern of the
tabernacle is extremely fascinating
because in a description we could take
that pattern of the tabernacle and we
could stretch it out to encompass
everything else that we've already seen
okay imagine this is the mountain now so
in moving out of the world so to speak
moses regains the world so for example
in its most hidden place the tabernacle
is equivalent to that lonely place where
Moses encountered God and the menorah
that seven-branch candlestick which is
in the Holy of Holies st. gregory makes
equivalent to those rays of light of the
spirit and also to the pillars of the
church and he talked about the pillows
already talk about the pillars of the
tabernacle which are the pillars of the
church quote all who themselves support
the church
and become lights through their own
works are called pillars and lights and
so they're Saints of course but also all
of us who participate in the life of the
church we become pillars and lights of
the church you are the light of the
world that is lords the Apostle unquote
so this light that he sees in the
pattern of the tabernacle is the very
light that Moses encounters as he was
ascending the mountain and finally the
biggest mystery of all is that on the
edge of the tabernacle the outer cover
of that tabernacle is made of animal
skins animal skins which are dyed red
and so the beauty is that just like in
the burning bush those dead skins which
were removed and the ascent are found
again though transformed and what were
the enslaving passions are now The
Passion of Christ and there's even water
down there if you notice as the people
entered into the tabernacle they had to
wash themselves before the entrance
quote even if one sees skin dyed red and
hair woven the sequence of contemplation
is not broken this way for the prophetic
eye attaining to a vision of divine
things will see the saving passion their
predetermined it is signified in both
the elements mentioned the redness
pointing to blood and the hair to death
I think regular tells us that quote hair
on the body has no feeling hence it is
rightly a symbol of death unquote all
right we're starting to get the full
image here one of the things that is
encountered by Moses is the in the
heavenly tabernacle is the pattern of
priesthood which is given to Moses and
so this makes this whole pattern this
whole mountain analogical to the
ecclesiastical hierarchy which is later
elaborated in DNA cynthy ology but
what's fascinating is that in that
section where it talks about attaining
priesthood and gaining the pattern of
priesthood in the in the
the divine Tabernacle he also traces now
the dark side of the ascent I told you
everything has two sides and so there's
a dark side to the ascent he speaks of a
false ascent of the mountain it's the
ascent of pride which can bring men to
gain the priesthood for themselves in
order to bolster their own passion and
so the passion of licentiousness and of
idolatry which we we picture as
wallowing in the mire at the bottom of
the mountain now finds its pair and this
mock ascent which is accomplished in
Pride
so everything even the ascent has a
light and a dark side now okay I've only
I've only brushed the surface of what
st. Gregory deals with and I encourage
all of you to explore this book on your
own and discover the wealth that is that
it offers but if we look at the map here
I think we have enough elements to get a
sense of what this is about so please
look at it carefully okay
we have the feminine which is mother
education and the church or else it is
profane knowledge and the world the
foreigner who is the tyranny of idolatry
but is also the profane knowledge and
can become our wife and friend as we
move forward we have animality which are
our passions and should be removed but
they can also be transfigured we have
this process of purification water fire
baptism circumcision we have the
masculine which is Moses in Moses is the
virtua individual but can also be the
tyrant in the fair and we see the
brother angel who is a counselor for
good or evil depending which way we're
going we have the true ascent towards
divinity in the priesthood and the false
ascent which is
fruit of Pride and finally we have the
darkness which is encountered at the
bottom and at the top of the mountain
with like and music in the middle and
above it all there is the divine
Tabernacle which is Christ and which
even beyond the unknowability of
divinity paradoxically resolved all
those dualities gathers all things into
himself unites all opposites and is
simply all-in-all now try to keep this
basic pattern in your memory ok it
shouldn't be so difficult because in
theory the elements here are intuitive
or they should make sense to us on a
very basic level ok
everybody got it now what do you see the
pattern there is light the outside of
the circle there is darkness the inner
darkness within and there is the divine
Tabernacle not made with hands
there is the mountain and there in the
circle ours of sandals removed in order
to attain the vision there is the ascent
and the descent of the mountain and I
didn't tell you the positive descent of
the mountain but it also has a positive
because when we descend the mountain we
can be descending it because we're
falling but we can be descending and
bringing the law down to the people we
can be descending bringing the vision of
God to the world do you see the pattern
there's a divine darkness there are the
their the rays of light all the pillars
of the church and there is the outer
darkest at the bottom now the older
versions of this icon didn't use the
King cosmos they actually use the
foreigners so they would put all the
different tribes and all the different
foreigners represented inside and you
surely in the middle there was a dog
headed man who represented that final
monster that final chaos that frog on
the edge of what being is now if you
take this and you flip it around and you
think of the Tower of Babel whether you
have you have the same structure making
taking clay making bricks and building
this false ascent of a tower up to reach
to God and what's the result of that the
creation of foreigners I do see the
pattern it's going to keep asking that
there's a divine darkness the rays of
light and in this icon it's not so much
as much the bottom the descent of the
mountain is the descent into the
mountain so it's an it's a slight change
but it's the same thing the cavern
becomes this wound its tomb at the same
time and so there's the mother
and there's the tomb on which Christ is
laid there are the animals next to
Christ which represent those garments of
skin there are the two foreigners the
helpful foreigner who come to serve
Christ and the harmful foreigner who
comes to tempt Joseph and down there
just to make sure there's the water that
have the water down there I'm gonna show
you one last one but I could have 25
here I'm going to show you one last one
can you see it faster there's the divine
darkness there's the light there's
there's the tabernacle the angels ascend
on one side the demons descend on the
other the Saints are the pillars they
are the lights of the church and in this
one particular one there's an amazing
vision of the womb on one side which is
pear
and the church and the Theotokos and on
the other side there is the grave you
see that you see that circle with those
strange brown that are those are the
dead coming out of their tombs and
what's bringing them out of their tombs
music of course and so I would just
encourage you to just think when you go
to liturgy and you see it's everywhere I
mean this is just this is just like a
hint I mean I had two Iife when I first
wrote this it was like two hours long
okay so just cut cut because I'm just
cutting everything but it's just an
amazing thing
Reed Reed st. Gregory and read the
scriptures with this vision and it's
just it just it just astounds us every
time it astounds me until today and I
get knocked over all the time just by
how amazing our God is and how amazing
his creation is so thank you